hey guys Greg Alva here it's 2017 happy
new year I'm pretty sick right now I got
body aches my head feel I feel very
lightheaded I got a sore throat stuffy
nose I got it all going on right now but
I wanted to get this video out before it
it became too irrelevant of a topic
today instead of doing a top 10 favorite
movies or worst movies I'm going to do
more specific list this time top 5
favorite action scenes of 2016 I wrote
down many action scenes and I narrowed
it down to five most of them are comic
book movies just giving you a heads up
but here are my five interested here
with your guys's 5rb let's start off
with my number five my number 5 scene is
Wolverines fight scene and x-men
apocalypse it was a big fan of this
movie it's rather forgettable I think
it's bryan singer's most flawed x-men
film with that being said though the
cameo by weapon x is wolverine was
absolutely fantastic while we've got an
awesome fight scenes of wolverine
slashing up some other [ __ ] in
previous x-men films before none of them
have been like this this one was brutal
it was really shown an animalistic side
to Wolverine this moment is essentially
redoing Wolverines origin of that
specific time when he had the adamantium
place in his body the way Hugh Jackman
performs this one scene he has is so
well done is no sympathy for human life
it is just pure survival at this moment
he's like an animal being provoked by
you know being attacked I feel that this
scene alone if there was just a little
more attention to detail on the wounds
of these soldiers that there was just a
little bit more blood that this seemed
alone would have guarded the film an R
rating I mean there's a moment that's
pretty violent but because it's like not
gory he actually thrusts his claws
underneath a soldier's chinch and then
he throws him against the wall and it's
painful to watch it's a brutal moment
and like as we saw in the Logan red band
trailer that he does that to a ball dude
and then he goes under the chin with the
claws pop out of the back of the ball
guys had showing like oh this this is
why this is a red band trailer so I feel
like this moment alone sets us up for a
more brutal
kind of Wolverine in the Logan movie
that was just really cool to see this
very animalistic side of Logan because
he's not fighting for anyone but himself
at this specific moment my number four
choice is the brief byte sequence in
rogue one a Star Wars story where Darth
Vader is going through the hallway [ __ ]
it up a bunch of rebel soldiers if you
look back at the original Star Wars
trilogy there's really not a whole lot
of Vader fighting and the five secrets
is we're from several decades ago and I
feel that fight choreography has greatly
improved over the years at the same time
though this updated sequence of Vader
fighting is much more than how the Star
Wars prequels did their fights because
the prequels have much more fancy
lightsaber work a lot more fancy
choreography they do lack an emotional
intensity to this sequence of Road one
is the only fight scene that actually
features a lightsaber and while it's
more choreographed than anything we've
seen of Darth Vader in the past it
capitalizes on the wrathful force of his
dark side he's moving through the small
crowd of soldiers deflecting their
lasers slicing them up and one thing I
really enjoyed two was the use of the
force in the fight one thing that
bothers me in a lot of movies where an
action hero has some form of like
telekinesis is they don't seem to use it
when it would help them out the most I
think that awesome Chateau fight scene
in The Matrix Reloaded like it's
brilliantly choreographed but i feel
that neo could have easily forced
punched those dudes in some way or use
the blades and threw it out them
anything and then you would have been
able to grab Trinity Morpheus and the
keymaster none of the freeway if I would
have had to happen or kylo Ren's fight
scene with him against Rey and Finn in
the force awakens like that fight starts
off with kylo force pushing ray into a
tree knocking her out those abilities he
could have easily knocked out Finn as
well or just force choke them or
whatever I mean for that by you can
argue that kylo Ren was in some way
playing with his food but it still
doesn't feel well justified enough to me
for why he's not using the force
invaders fight in rogue one he uses a
lot of the force as he's going through
the soldiers like I think the highlight
moment of that fight was when he uses
the Force to put a soldier on the
ceiling blocks a few lasers and as he's
passing the soldier above him he just
slices through him and then continues
fighting and the emotional intensity the
fight is so well put there that it kind
of makes you feel that like if this
movie was made before a new hope that
this would have been a great way to set
up Vader as the main villain for
you hope so while it's Vader's shortest
fight not including you know Hayden
Christensen is Edison Skywalker today
again you can it hands down made for his
most badass fight my number three choice
has got to be from a film that I felt
was a major disappointment but
ultimately did deliver a fight scene
that I wanted to see for many years that
would be the batman fight scene and
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice in the
fight scene yes we had to see Batman
uses gadgets to take out bad guys but
most importantly we got to see the
incredibly skilled fighter that he is I
absolutely love the dark knight trilogy
i really enjoy all of them my one main
complaint with the trilogy awwready
live-action batman interpretation before
Nolan's Batman films was specifically
the fight scenes featuring Batman I've
been saying for years that I've wanted
to see Batman is a true martial artist
while they established that in the dark
knight trilogy the fight scenes didn't
really break any new ground in terms of
exploring Batman's fighting capabilities
because of the way Batman suit is this
I'm like Tim Burton's Batman movie or
Nolan's Batman movie he can't really
move that fluidly or do as many moves
that he could do without the suit
because the suit kind of keeps him a
little stiff but in bbs the fight scene
allows us to seek Batman is a brutal
force of a martial artist while
incorporating good batty gadgets
throughout I also appreciated that
Batman isn't perfect in this fight he
gets hit a couple times he gets stabbed
at one point even gets shot in the head
at one point I like having moments like
that where you see this guy really is a
human being you can't dodge everything
and not only giving us enhance martial
arts choreography we got to see him
break a lot of [ __ ] bones and it was
cool to just see the lethal weapon of
Batman who can just shatter your body so
yeah I was just happy to see Batman as a
ruthless lethal martial artist my number
two choice is a sanctum fight scene in
Doctor Strange this movie alone I fell
is an absolute delight it's fight
sequences were especially amazing it was
this one in particular really stood out
to me though this is the first fight
where dr. strange has learned a lot of
powers and is now using the magic to
fight against evil I mainly love this
sequence just because of how purely
imaginative it was like it does have its
moments or reminds you of the matrix and
inception especially when the guys are
like running up the walls and [ __ ] and
the mind-bending reality like to keep
all the magical powers alive throughout
this very well Cory
fight sequence and its choreography like
this that I feel gets overlooked
especially in comic book movies because
we just expect them to be great fights
but we don't take the time to go who are
the guy is choreographing these five
teens I still haven't looked it up so in
this sequence and work it's more than
just kicks and punches or just straight
weapons because the weapons these
characters have are their magical
abilities and i felt absolutely wowed by
this suspense back with imagination
because we saw a lot of these powers
being performed whether it being the
opening sequence of the film with the
ancient one or when you're seeing dr.
strange just training so this scene
allowed it to be contained in a rather
smaller environment than a lot of the
fight scenes in Doctor Strange come up
with unique ways to eliminate the bad
guys like throwing them out those
windows and stuff it's segues into that
awesome hospital fight that I love to
counter my tummy with the frighteners
and it also gave us dr. Strange's
awesome capes it showed us new things
that refined powers that were being
shown to us earlier and it also had a
great emotional intensity because this
is dr. Strange's first fight we know
he's a rookie and probably doesn't have
as strong powers as a lot of these other
guys so he asked to use the thing that
makes dr. strange especially special
which is the ability to outwit these
guys all right here it is my number one
top choice is probably on everyone's
list as well the airport battle sequence
in Captain America Civil War so in this
fight you got captain america the winter
soldier Falcon Scarlet Witch Ant Man
Iron Man war machine spider-man Black
Widow Hawkeye envision now in terms of
just comic book fight scenes alone this
has got to be easily one of the top ones
you've got so many characters we've seen
in Prior films just decking it out now
and each one of them gets just enough
screen time to truly show what makes
them awesome and also gives us a chance
to see some newer abilities this fight
scene is also packed with a lot of
personality it doesn't just only become
a fight scene the humor comes to life
especially with spider-man ant-man so
you still get funny dialogue from a lot
of them throughout the fight and even
the fighting moments with spider-man you
still get to see what makes this
spider-man different what up McGwire
still had some of his jokes Andrew
Garfield left at Aunt still get this
vibe but there's a high school kid
underneath this costume like you really
feel like he's still a kid
and they manage to include giant man
which is just they lay a super wow
moment for people and a nice surprise I
love the interplay of one switching
around someone which characters are
fighting which at the time this fight
really took what makes everyone very
specific and unique and have them at
moments go okay let's see these two
fight each other let's see these two
fight each other let's see these guys go
at it now would they battle each other
everyone's fighting abilities was so
specifically tailored it was so cool to
see a lot of unique kind of fighting all
being meshed into one and while a lot of
them do martial arts in the fight and
had the right blend of actual fighting
weaponry fighting and superpower
abilities bringing all these characters
personalities and powers to life with a
powerhouse action sequence that just
really gets your heart pumping and
you're smiling it's intense and it's so
cool it's like all the emotions you'd
want to feel out of an amazing spectacle
and just so i can mention this there
were other fights that I thought about
putting out as my top five but they just
didn't quite make the top five the
opening freeway action scene and
Deadpool the final showdown with Captain
America and Bucky versus Iron Man in
civil war the Las Vegas car chase scene
and Jason Bourne Quicksilver rescuing
people from the exploding mansion in
Xmen apocalypse and Donnie ants fight
scene against the stormtroopers in rogue
one alright guys well it's my top five
favorite fight scenes of 2016 I did not
catch every movie and I know there's a
couple of films that featured some
action that I did not catch what were
your guys is top five or what are that
what are the movies you think in 2017
that will deliver the best action
sequences if you're new to the channel
subscribe today we could use another
subscriber I hope you're the one i think
i'm gonna take a nyquil now smoke a
joint which will probably not be good
for my throat but [ __ ] it weed